who's the race car driver that we always
make fun of the main guy lewis lewis
hamilton they just chopped this
drop 10 in there i was i was going to
joke watch millie get with a dude way
shorter than him yeah feels louis yeah
yeah 10 seconds yeah how is he how tall
is he five eight like five eight yeah
imagine they just drop him in there he's
like he just walks through hello
no bro yo what's up
[Music]
yo what's up it's famous race car driver
lewis hamilton
he wouldn't even have to say that much
he just walk in there with his mercedes
hat yeah they'd be like
oh my god oh my god is that lou's hammer
[ __ ] off
it's lewis hamilton hello girls
i'm just here for a few days before my
next race would be so funny if they just
dropped like harry styles in there or
something like that something just to
just to turn the knife in liam's stomach
you know
because they'd go for millie you know
they would yeah
i don't know if they would she's like
she's the coolest you know
sure yeah you don't know bro you know
how lewis is
louis might run through that whole
building yeah that's true
at the same time yeah just and girls
want to go to the hideaway
no you've got to come back with me don't
go in there
lewis hamilton my limb
no my limb come on girls
meet me in my mercedes patronus
sponsored hideaway
oh my god louise all the girls go in
there yeah
and all the dudes are left that night
just to
lewis wins the 50k and all seven girls
and the season's over
it literally happens in like four hours
they watch them all
just have an orgy and then he walks out
and then ian sterling comes out with
this lady and they're like show's over
lou it says when it's all yeah man i
think
i think liam's done after this i think
he's gonna grovel and it's not gonna
work
and then he's gonna be too depressed to
crack on with anyone else well here's
another thing is now there's like 40
people in the house
like i don't think there's ever been
this many people that have come back to
the show after caso moore has like a
permanent fixture
so like they're gonna have to dump like
three couples in the next like week
they'll probably be public vote
yeah so whoever liam is is gonna be
like if millie couples up with him then
they may save her yeah but if he's
coupled up with anyone else which he
probably will be
yeah he's out who else is out i don't
think toby's gonna go because i think he
creates too much drama toby's gonna stay
because now he's got this fantastic uh
like narrative upcoming in today's
episode
yeah where he says to the he goes to the
interview camera as if this dude hasn't
been
undecisive enough he looks at the camera
he goes
i came back with what's-her-face mary
mary i brought mary i brought mary back
uh abby stayed single cause she thought
for some reason
i would too so she still wants me but
my head is with chloe who was the
previous girl that he was with khloe
like this dude is just [ __ ] marry khloe
yeah exactly
unreal it's unreal at the top of the
season when he goes
you know i've never been in a
relationship i just i'm excited to
sample everything i want to
taste like how you described it i want
to sample every little thing yeah
he lived up to it yeah yeah he did it
yeah
so i think he's going to stay cause he's
he's the heel they need him now
yeah uh the public needs someone to hate
yeah i think tyler's out yeah
um yeah because i think
he i think i think he was probably the
most misbehaved
in castlemore def like him and he came
into the show and was like kaz is my
girl
like was chatting her up kaz had never
had up into that point like a real
connection with anyone
he gets in a real connection with her
like very
upfront blatantly makes it like i'm
about you like yeah this is great
and they're like hitting it off talking
all the time yeah and then he goes to
casamore first thing he does first night
is his makeup with a girl
in bed that's like the worst thing you
could do yeah besides
full-on smash yep and i think i
also i doesn't help his case because kaz
i think is
definitely like a fan favorite yeah so
yeah he just he shot himself twice there
yeah so i think he's
he's out yeah now i i i i think faye's
going to pick teddy
yeah i think so too he's going to go
with sam they kissed
didn't they yeah in yesterday's episode
i guess
so they're back if somehow abby stays i
feel like she's gonna go for dale
just because you know i think tattoo
people just kind of go together
that's totally fair isn't she a tattoo
artist yeah
okay so you know yeah that back tattoo
is
[ __ ] intense it's crazy it's nuts
yeah it looks like it's really nuts at
first glance you look at it and you
think
you know it was done in some original
like cultural way
like it looks like stabbed into her skin
yeah
i don't know there's like one shot where
her back was red as hell just around the
tattoo yeah
bugged me out um yeah if they have to
get rid of three couples it would be
like tyler and
clarice liam and whoever and then tyler
and
i said that already yeah liam and
whoever and who else i say is going to
go
um oh like what about sam yeah
sam and it'd be like sam and abby like
sam and mary yeah
and matthew known because matthew's
lucas yeah
yeah i mean i think yeah faye's
definitely picking teddy
yeah it's a it's a done deal there yep
and you know what
i would actually venture to say they
have a shot at winning it
because i think jake [ __ ] his image up
i think everyone thinks he's a snake and
i think teddy he really did he did kiss
that girl
in the dare and then he slept outside
you're trying my trends wearing off
our uh yeah our body is we're kind of on
the down cycle right now guys yeah so
we're just getting like weird you know
eczema
conditions wrinkles and kind of like
tumors almost
yeah you definitely need to cycle up for
next episode for sure
you definitely look like you're falling
apart a little bit i'm looking i'm
melting yeah a little bit
muscles are just slowly like that's a
hot day we definitely have to inject off
yeah i gotta you know
how do you feel about the little games
that they play because i personally i
can
rarely engage like i kind of don't give
a [ __ ] when they play those games which
games
you know like you know today they're
playing
aging in disguise oh the challenge yeah
challenges challenges yeah
i mean those challenges i don't know
i yeah i don't really [ __ ] with it
either they're just stupid
yeah i can't imagine how long it would
take to actually shoot that
like how like imagine them all going
through that [ __ ]
stupid you know like the cop one or
whatever yeah that whole obstacle course
that they're doing
it's like 20 people have to go through
that no
like it takes like chopping it down it
ends up being like 10 minutes but
they're standing there for like two
hours yeah
like trying to have fun yeah in this
stupid ass challenge
that's why i've really been enjoying the
episodes for the last two weeks because
i'm like this is what i want to see yeah
i don't see them
except the puking the messy yeah
uh fetish or whatever i i cut
i'm with that because are you a wet and
messy i'm a wet and messy
you know what messy yeah that's why we
watch this show wow
i mean i do like the slow-mo shots with
their on the vibrating platform
and they're you know and a woman is butt
ass naked trying to keep her
tiny ass eating suit on i like that
[Laughter]
you know love seeing a bird just like
vibrating their clothes
i shoot off in front of national tv i
love it